All right, we are
back for let's say an
hour. Going to try to get a few few more
things done
here. Creep is
going. I mean, that's
something. Yeah, look at this. We have
experiments. Uh
score.
Uhhuh. This is one
E8. So 100
mil relative
time. 29
seconds. Possibly gets way faster. We'll
see.
Decent
runs. All right. What are we going to do
here? Kind of just want to like check
the
uh
dues. I mean, we did most of the stuff I
wanted to do today,
still going to need stuff like
Atari that stuff all fixed
up. I want to just hang around like
running little experiments, right?
check. Actually, the pong speedrun thing
would be a kind of a cool gif.
But it's a little silly how uh long You
know what? Why don't we just
like just figure out something with the
comms?
Maybe like how many flops should comms
be.
folks, I'd like to just find like, you
know, the one extra thing I can do
today because I'm pretty tired, but I
I'd like to just at least find like one
extra thing I can get done.
Neural MMO 3 PF
stuff like a
Maybe. I can
probably there are a couple
optimizations I could think of to be
fair. What about
um impulse
wars? Oh yeah, the other thing was uh
with breakout
uh I didn't realize we had frame skip in
there. That's kind of bad.
What are you guys still doing in here?
We're just chatting. All right. Yeah,
just chatting. That's what all those
people on Twitch are doing always. Just
chatting. We're chatters. that was, you
know, quarying him as to some of the
research that he's that he's done
recently. And
I'm trying to find like one more thing I
can do tonight, even though I'm kind of
tired. How was dinner? Dinner's good.
What was dinner?
Uh,
salad and meatballs and mashed
potatoes. Good. Sounds
good. As long as it's not a weird salad.
No. Good
salad. Let me think.
Uh, you want to do something? Depends on
how easy you want. I'm just trying to
think of like stuff I can get done for
the release. It's because it's like one
thing after another. It is one thing
after
another. Uh, there's there's uh someone
mentioned they have a environment that
they PR. Who did
uh someone in Oh, the CPR M.
Yeah, CPR. Yep.
Uh I can merge that stuff. The thing is
I kind of have to like merge all this
into
dev at some point.
Well, you ch you choose whether or not
you want
to merge, you know, stuff
into the release branch and then into
dev or just into dev. And then either
way, you're going to be looking
If I could figure out how to get it so
that you can actually build the damn
package, that would be nice.
I know. All right.
There is a way to
add wait build padicans are
typically do TOML usage.
What is TOML?
TAML. Hi Project TML.
Yeah, it's another setup.pyish.
See the issue is I need to have
different build
backends or different what's this
command
class different command
put stuff into Grock and see if it just
leads me down rabbit holes that don't
make any bloody sense like it usually
does.
lucky. That's this library that I'm
building
Next week will be fun. We get many more
deliveries to
up. Let's see what this rock told us to
do.
this thing. I hate Python tooling so
much. It's just like so
ass, you
know, just bad.
And
like the devs should feel bad because
the code is
I wish we could just get rid of pietor
torch. Honestly, it's like
H. Can we like build our own? That's
better.
I have news for you.
You could in
fact build your own. That would be fun.
Or go back to TensorFlow.
No, that sounds worse. Oh, that also
sounds pretty bad.
I could Yeah, I could try some Tiny
Grad.
At least those devs care about building
stuff. That's good.
bloated. It does a lot these days. I
managed to get an error on build that
prompted me to an internal Facebook
login.
Huh.
So
like
Yeah. Facebook handed over control to
Linux though. Yeah. But they they
literally link you to like internal
thing like, "Oh, this is hard. You
should get
thanks." Yeah. I don't buy the Zuck
Maker for one minute. We know you're an
android.
figure this thing out tonight. I can
actually merge it and not have everybody
hate
Huh? Is what I pasted there the air you
you get?
No. Did I ship something bad? I mean,
all I did was run set up. I didn't did
not comment. I have it just
the This is release branch, of course.
there and it is committed. So I don't
know why there's no semicolon there.
Expect a semicolon before wait hang on
the previous
line.
Uh, maybe
I don't see a missed semicolon. I'll try
to build it in a second. I don't see it
either.
There should be no um Syon in here at
all.
because in in setup there's a scythe.
Yeah, but there's no
You don't call extension paths?
I don't see it
anywhere.
Am I looking at the wrong set of file? I
don't call that
siphoniz
shouldn't need to freaking siphonize
torch. This rock your fave. I just got
sick of
like all of the freaking companies
leaprogging each other every other month
and people just having to hop around
constantly with a million different
subscriptions. I just have this. It's
included with
uh you know with X membership which I
already
have. It's like going to be the best
like one month out of four.
Yeah, that's weird. Yeah, I had a
different
Python packaging is just
awful. Like, this is just awful
[ __ ] It's not [ __ ] documented
properly either at all.
For some
reason, we're just calling
Syon. That's weird. Yeah, these things
happen. I don't know. My boy also uses
siphon in in compilation, but doesn't
actually like use it.
fix RL then fix Python. Nah, I think if
I fix RL, it's probably going to be fix
aging
next because that one seems like a real
[ __ ]
Even when I take Sipyhon out of the
build
requires, it still uses it.
Oh, we should uh we should probably make
sure we put requires Python 312. Brian
Johnson's only trying to like minorly
reduce aging, not fix it.
Oh, okay. So, was it not supposed to
compile or
something? Uh, it doesn't work. Is
anyone trying to fix it?
Uh Max
Yadderberg is doing cool stuff at the
moment, but he's doing like general drug
discovery, curing diseases. I don't know
if he considers aging a
disease, and I don't know if there's
like a drug that fixes
it. But like I said, it might just be AI
complete. It just it might be that
people like we're too stupid to solve it
anytime in the near future unless we
just AI.
I don't know.
I'm not I wouldn't know until I look at
it, right?
problem. Has anybody like ever seriously
tried to even do that?
How is it that there's like they have a
[ __ ] arc that's just not documented
anywhere that I can see at all?
welcome. All right, I have an idea. I
have an idea on how we might fix this.
doesn't help that the LLMs are just
really
stupid. They can't solve problems that
are hard or that they haven't trained
on.
Yeah, but it doesn't even go like Yeah.
I don't know. It just like gives me
stupid [ __ ] You have to you have to
tell it. You have to tell it have a
specific custom instruction like oh if
you don't know just tell me you don't
know and that's it.
I'm pretty sure that there have been
ablations on stuff like that. You can't
just say hey like hey and don't be
stupid like it doesn't work.
You can tell it just don't tell me you
just tell me you don't know it will it
GPT will tell you yeah I don't know.
Congratulations, you've solved LM
hallucination.
No, not at all. Because that's how they
work, right?
Like they're they're hallucinating
things that happen to be right.
Basically,
not really.
Transformers.
I mean, you hallucinate stuff that
doesn't even happen to be right. Yeah.
Well, I
like it. just be incorrect thinking,
right?
Okay, let's see if I can do it with
this
2D of a 2D pose estimation from Wi-Fi
signals. Oh, yeah. There's some weird
stuff you can do with Wi-Fi, isn't
there?
I'm sure there is. There's some weird
stuff you can get out of Wi-Fi that you
wouldn't expect that you can
get.
I probably cool. I don't see if there's
RL applicable in any way, but you
know, probably cool.
What I think about project is if you
think it's cool, then you should you
should go for it.
There is no one one truth. I'm kind of
one.
Well, besides besides the puffer.
Puffer is truth. The fish got to eat.
Hey, I'm just saying servers ain't
cheap.
Yeah, freaking tiny boxes plus 12 GPUs
though.
What did those come to?
51 grand.
Oh my
god. Mhm.
So, do you just like put that on a
credit card? Wire transfer.
You You don't You don't just put it on a
credit. No one's gonna No one's going to
take that. Yeah. My I got two MX blocks
to handle it.
Yeah. No, I don't have a 50k credit
card.
Well, I mean, companies do have crazy
credit cards. I do have a 25K credit
card that they just randomly gave me for
no reason. Yeah, they'll do that. They
want you to they they want you to borrow
at, you know, 35% APR. But
like, yeah, it's
funny. Thoughts on Verl and
Deepcaler? Am I supposed to know what
either of these are?
No, it's Deep Scaler Joseph.
I have no idea what either of these are.
Yeah, I I don't know those things. If
this is LLM stuff, like I'm not going to
be up to date with it.
Whoa, I just compiled it, I think. Is it
this volcano engine reinforcement
learning?
Like I don't keep up with all the LLM
stuff. Like everyone else is doing LLMs.
I'm sitting here like the one person not
doing LLMs.
Even I had to recently do language
models. See, enjoy your language models.
More sloth. But I don't like the
language models.
slop.
There there will be there will be big
big money in developing a coherent
interface.
There's big money in a ton of stuff if
you're smart. Well, sure if you're smart
andor very hard
worker. Emphas emphasis on the hard
worker.
I don't know. I put decent hours in.
Yeah, just a
bit. See if this does
anything. Custom
build. What is it like?
What approaches do is they have a pair
of signal features of a
frame image
frame. That sounds like supervised
learning. You need there needs to be an
element of interactivity. day.
I had Jeb and I do a deep research on uh
on our setup.py.
It's hilarious.
It's compiled the results. They don't
use the image at all. They just use the
post data. some ideas to try
Jeppa. I'll make a backbone.
And yeah, that that all sounds like
standard supervised learning stuff,
right?
Yeah, nope.
Like here's the thing,
right? Like if you ask a researcher if
he's heard of a
thing, the answer is most likely going
to be no, but like could read and
understand paper even if it's outside of
immediate area of expertise quite
That's easy. All you have to do is
uninstall X.
But Joseph, where would I get my news?
Yeah, where would I get my uh my
advertising from? Right.
They've they've Yeah, they've improved
the recommendation system.
I reproduce what they made most likely.
Yeah. Any advice?
I mean, make sure you are getting
something that is like relatively
straightforward to
reproduce. I can tell you a lot of
projects,
um, you spend like 3 to six months
trying to reproduce something and find
that the original kind of just isn't
what it was claimed to be. Or maybe it
is, but it's finicky as hell.
an idea for doing annotations using RL
be
applicable. A lot of examples of human
annotators you need a way to verify is
the problem.
annotations without a way to verify that
they're actually correct.
Why am I not paper clips? You are. You
just haven't realized it yet.
The RL is so good it made you paper
clips and then RL you to not even
realize that you're made of paper
clips. Did I do it?
I compiled something and my training is
running. Whoa,
Yeah, that's actually kind of promising.
Uh, try try
What did you put?
Setup's up high.
The last thing
the whole thing.
You're
building the and torch.
Yeah, man. I weird because I had
something like this and just been the
order then.
Like the order could have just been off.
I'd also prefer to not have it do. It's
kind of jank like jamming them into
one conditional command like that. Try
to try to try to run it and see if it
runs on yours because I I did change
something in M binding.
The thing is like it's
I believe that
works. It's just it's so freaking
sketch.
Well, there's there's the other option.
I I hate GPT, by the way. But there's G
GPT's
thoughts. I I hate it because I mean it
omitted like most of the file, right?
Like yeah, I said whole file. I didn't
say omit everything. So
there are some things. Maybe it cleaned
it up. I don't know. I didn't review it
super super
super carefully,
but both seem to compile. Just a moment.
I'm observing the rabbit that has just
jumped right outside my window. Is it
like on the window sill or No, it's like
I don't know 20 ft away.
Is it like eating stuff? It's just
chilling.
Yeah, that's what rabbits do and they
poop everywhere.
Yeah, literally just there eating grass.
It'll be pooping,
too. I went to I went to, you know, lay
the perimeter water for the robot mower
and uh Oh, you No, man. The rabbits are
not a problem. You believe me? We have
geese here. All right. Geese are awful.
Geese are freaking awful. Yeah, geese
are not. Yeah.
Neither of us really particularly cares
for the the Canada goose. No,
I hear they're going to have to pay
tariffs at the border.
Yo, Aaron, can you take your geese back?
Nope.
You to keep them now. It's personal. You
see? You see? They dropped the geese in
our country and they won't even take
them back. That's I'm coming back in
less than a month. Oh, you think you
are? You're going to come back if maybe
if you take your geese, we'll think
about it.
You want me to swap places with the
geese? Yeah, we'll take we'll take you
and then Canada can have all the
freaking geese back.
Make sure in your next grant you got to
make sure you have geese in there.
Otherwise, it's going to get rejected.
I'll tell you what, we'll trade Canada.
We'll give you geese back and give us
some of those harp seals you have.
What are you going to do with them? I
don't know. Keep them. They're cool.
Keep them.
They might have other other ideas about
that. I don't know. They're
chill. They're just chill. They'll just
like lounge around. I don't know. Feed
them some fish.
Yeah. Sounds
smelly. Nothing. Nothing against seals
as animals. Yeah. You kind of need to
hose them down.
torch.
Oh, I see.
So, without the without the changes,
uh it's not compiling. Now, I made three
changes to uh fb binding.
Let me just see if
uh GPT's version compiles.
It's like it's doing some weirdo stuff
here. It's like compiling this stuff.
This change here, this change should fix
it without breaking
it. All right.
Each one of them each one of them needs
to be
Yeah, that does break it.
What does it do? Well, like for
observations in particular, it totally
should break it because the point is
that it's a cast from a void star.
Oh, that's the old. That's the old.
You're going to replace. Sorry, that was
not clear. Let me Let me get rid of this
thing. I don't know why it's messing
with this anyways. Why is it giving me
an error on something that shouldn't be
an error? One sec. I I have the
solution. Does it have like some
like does it have like like error like
error like error on warning or whatever?
Uh I don't think so. That's what it is
at the moment. That each each search
each of those three and replace replace
them with each of those. Okay. Action
still totally strong there.
I mean that does look a little sus.
Yeah, that's It's you compiled like one
ember or whatever.
Like they're gonna have different data
types depending on the end. The point
was that it's a cast from a void star.
Yeah. Right. So that you could actually
use it. I wonder and like I it's just it
annoys me that like I know that this is
valid C and it's like there's some
[ __ ] argument in
here like C++ 17 or whatever. I don't
know why this is like it's CC code.
It's trying to compile my [ __ ] with C++,
which pisses me off.
Yeah.
So, if we run an environment that maybe
we do have to do your style of thing. I
I think I can clean it up a bit.
Mode train. What's one that has uh Oh,
cartpole should be
jank. All right, we're going to print
these actions.
them? Oh, it's because I have this line
in
here. We remove that.
breaks. You said that there's clipping
in there already.
Okay, then I we can get rid of this
whole
Well, the clipping's in the clean puff
for real, right? So, in the in the uh
Python file for the
app, we just do salted actions. Well, it
depends. It's not the worst idea to clip
it if it's going to break the end
anyways.
actions open bracket colon close bracket
equals actions worked.
Interesting. Let's see if it trains.
survey
says. Oh, got my hopes up there,
too. I wonder if this is in the
hyperparameters.
Like it drives me nuts that like cuz I
don't even want this to work almost cuz
like I don't want to have to maintain
this piece of [ __ ]
Like that's we're we're like this
packaging is just so ass. Like I don't
know who the [ __ ] thought this was a
good idea. The way that this is set up,
this is just monumentally [ __ ]
stupid. Like the fact that you can't
easily apply different setup to
different extensions without going
through this whole weirdass command
system is just garbage.
Yeah.
Know I I agree.
But I'm like trying to think how I
replace this and I'm just like coming up
blank with alternatives. Yeah. Well, the
other alternatives are also garbage.
That's that's the issue. They're all
kind of
Did you have to do the thing where you
like set the extensions temporarily to
like only some of them?
No, that's what you have in there.
Is is is it not compiling everything
because it should be.
All right. It's just so ass. Everything
works or really ass
like spec specifically what what about
it is ass
the fact that I have to like separate
all the these freaking extensions down
here and then I resort through them and
then you have to [ __ ] like replace
you're like overriding the self
extensions temporarily to run this run
command. It's jank as
hell. This is like disgusting language
tooling. And it's like disgusting
language tooling. And literally the most
crucial thing to actually work in the
entire project, which is that your users
can [ __ ] install it.
I would agree.
Like I don't know. It's just baffling
how [ __ ] the state of Python tooling
is. Oh, look at this. Claude agrees with
you. The user is frustrated with
complexity of handling multiple
extension types instead of tools. And
they have a point.
Oh, wow. Sophant model says it's like
whatever. No, usually it doesn't because
I I you know make sure that it doesn't
have have stupid things that it's the
idea is for it to simply answer my
question and say nothing
else. It's a tool hopefully.
Yeah, I don't know where my torch
extensions are
extensions. They're at the top, aren't
they?
Maybe. I
Oh, then how is a train? cuz you already
have it cached.
Does it force? No, it doesn't. Cuz guess
what? The tooling sucks and nothing
works the way it's supposed to. Clean.
Damn. I don't know what the [ __ ] to do
at this point.
reach out to random people on the
internet. It's just like I how the [ __ ]
am I supposed to not only be able to get
this to work, but then maintain and
debug this across all the different
systems when the tooling is this [ __ ]
dog
And if I could just like write all my
stuff in C and never deal with this like
horrendous like language build system
again, I'd be very happy.
What would you use to compile?
ECC or
Clang. Like honestly, just writing C and
CUDA is like pretty chill. This is not
at all.
Like I'm just trying to think of like
what other way I could do the build
system and I just can't [ __ ] think of
I mean, like, honestly, the best way is
probably to just force it to work with
setup tools because everything else is
just going to introduce more dumbass
dependencies,
right? That's Yeah, it's like you're
locked to setup
tools. There's no alternative to setup
tools in Python, right?
I mean, I think there are a couple, but
there I think you're locked to set like
you're asking for things that are All
right.
Everything seems to compile fine. Do you
actually get do you get the binaries for
the torch extensions?
One
sec. Just trying to test up this
continuous. Interesting.
If it does actually build the torch
extension, let me know and uh like link
it and I will look at it in the morning.
I'm like very unhappy with the way that
this tooling is and like I don't know
how the [ __ ] we release a package with
the state that this stuff is in. Um
Upper lip
build lib.
Linux. Yeah, there I mean there's a
there's a file there. Let me just delete
this build folder.
Okay, I think I found
something. Maybe a little less ass.
I got it.
I got it in a way that's not total
ass. I need to figure out a better way
to do this filter,
but there should be a better way to do
this filter. But look, let's see. One
sec. I got to pull up the stream
train that
trains. Okay, so look, I got it. You see
this?
Waiting for the stream to catch up.
Uh, okay.
a lot simpler.
Right now, this filter bothers the hell
out of
This filter bothers the [ __ ] out of me.
But but it bothers you less than my my
version.
Maybe
my version does compile the the CUD. The
thing that's gross is that you have to
like this run doesn't take
extensions. As far as I can
tell, it relies on self
extensions to do jank overwriting of
Yeah. Yep. That's
that's seems to be the
solution. Um,
have you tried uh like pawn continuous
by the way? No.
Like I haven't tried that at all. It
might I mean it's probably doesn't work,
but
it it's more readily fixable than
uh the setup. Well, the setup's kind of
important. I I agree.
I got a thing. I think then um Monday or
whatever I
will I will try. Actually, let me commit
this. I guess on Monday I what I will
try to do is I will try to figure out a
relatively clean way to like get this
now with the Syon MC and everything so
that they don't
fight. Um,
and then we will go from there.
Sounds good. Cuz yeah, I think
continuous might be kind of broken now.
Yeah. Yeah.
That's for you to fix. Um, uh, that's
it. It took it took me quite a long time
to to figure out that fix, the so-called
fix that apparently wasn't a fix for,
uh, well, I mean, now it should just be
a matter of like figuring out how data
is getting passed there wrong or
whatever. I think it's all right,
though. That's the thing. Not sure then.
Yeah, you can, but you you should be
able to put break points in the C now
from the Python, so it shouldn't be that
that bad. Cool. Wait, really?
Yeah, that's the cool thing with the new
bindings, Aaron. Oh, that's so much
nicer. Yes, it there's no Syon.
It's very cool.
Um, but you know, it's it's a lot of
work to make this stuff simple because
it's basically like it really does feel
like the farther I get away from just
like chilling and writing C, the more
it's like I'm fighting every
[ __ ] developer out there who
just wants to do absolutely nothing but
make your life hell by just adding like
mounds and mounds of [ __ ] abstracted
garbage. It's like [ __ ] nuts.
So, it's like honestly when I'm
developing like when I'm writing CMS and
stuff, it's like chill and I feel like
I'm actually doing work. And when I'm
doing all this stuff in Python, it's
like I don't feel like I'm doing
anything as much as I feel like I'm just
fighting every other developer in
existence.
You might be. It's like actually
obscene. So, I'm like I'm going to do
more algorithm stuff. Obviously, it has
to be in Python or whatever for now, but
like I I got to find a way to get it get
myself to a place where I can be just
deving more like low-level stuff cuz
like god the code is just such a pain.
Yeah. I wish Torch had a C back end. I'd
just use it.
Doesn't
it jank at that? Oh.
Damn. Okay. There's like there's just
too much curse stuff, honestly. like,
you know, um I got I got like neural MMO
running like twice as fast on um it ran
like three times as fast on a 5090 as a
4090 with like very specific params, but
then everything else is like tiny tiny
differences. Yeah. And I know the 5090
is not 3x
faster. A bunch of jank stuff. Yep.
That sums it up.
It's okay. We'll get there. Yeah, job
security.
I definitely do need to expand at some
point with this because it's
like if we're going to be doing all
this, it's like we got to actually be
solving some some big some big problems.
was like, "Oh, you got to get like a
power grid optimization contract or
something to pay all the bills and then
I can just like do this properly."
Yeah.
We definitely want more machines.
Yeah. Here's the thing. You you go you
go in and the system they're using is
something that's not at all optimized,
then we'll rewrite it. But like if we're
going to be write rewriting stuff like
it's going to be for real money.
Rewrite. Yeah. I suppose you don't want
to do the uh the PyTorch re rewrite in
C.
I mean to be fair it doesn't necessarily
have to be rewritten as long as they can
provide you with the correct information
from their end and they're okay with you
know potentially some latency because of
the amount of time it takes to get their
data. I mean that that's what most
people would say. Linky, I don't
disagree. I think that's what happens in
the real world. Jo Joseph, uh it's
corporate to say the vault's in your
court, so figure it out without putting
liability on puffer.
You know, that's that's one way to look
at
it. Joseph's got a mission.
My mission is just to fix freaking fix
RL, right? and uh make enough money in
the process to fund uh a good deal of
private research. Oh, I think it's a lot
lotable goal. Uh it's good it's good to
have your your uh values too. When you
start compromising values, you know, not
necessarily selling out, but but you you
lose something.
No, I've definitely seen with some of
the client work, there are good clients
and there are bad clients.
Well, yeah. That's
the good clients are the ones who are
like who realize that it's like, oh,
okay, like these guys are so so
ridiculously far ahead of
uh the rest of RL that like it would be
crazy to not have them on our problem
and then they just like take all the
free soda results that we provide them.
Um because like you know we set soda
like that's that's a pretty damn good
result for you. Um the bad ones are
where it's like there's just for the
amount of the money the contract is
there just like heaps and heaps and
heaps and heaps of info that you can't
even work around or wrap or anything.
Um, you're just you're just mired in
like I realized like if we like we could
for instance we could do more stuff in
robotics but the cost is going to have
to go up substantially for the amount of
work that there's like there is to do
with that like I'm down I'm down to jam
a ton of code for that but it's got to
be it's got to be buy and servers.
My question is
what where do you think the cost is for
robotics? Just humor me for a moment. Uh
so basically they have 10 generations of
trauma inflicted on like PhD student
after PhD student wrapping each other's
garbage code and nobody's ever rather
like bothered to write it correctly.
Okay. It's horrible. So
yeah, that's fair. That sounds like an
inheritance myth. And yes, I mean
just legacy, I guess, because my thought
is you can at least intro into robotics.
I mean, we have the one binding that
isn't puff or
proprietary, but as a good like deep
um I guess emulation of
like proprietary is not a great word.
It's just uh I don't have a better word
for created first party. Yeah, first
party. So you can at least, you know,
middleman a lot of robotic stuff by
setting up maybe, prime example, a small
version of one of those industrial arms.
You can set one of those up with like
desktop servo servo motors and all that.
And there will be minute differences
between like pinouts and data lines, but
realistically all those can be weighted
between different arms. You just need
like a reference plane to know around
what weight to like some some motors
don't need near as much oomph to move
the arm as others. You would think so
and then you realize that there are like
five of those generations of trauma are
just PhD students doing that because all
the hardware like all the like the
hardware interface is insane.
Yeah. Like I'm not talking go out there
and get like Boston Dynamics materials
but I don't know. I think that for now
the the plan I have is pretty good for
now, which is finish this damn release
ASAP. Um, this release is we now have
measurably better algorithms than just
like PO but faster. We have some crazy
results. We're going to get some even
crazier results as we do all the sweeps
for everything. And then I'm probably
going to want to spend a month just like
figuring out all the other al I
basically I want to figure out
everything that Deep Mind figured out
and at least publish something of um in
the last seven years.
I want to like what if all their
research actually like is actually
useful versus what of it is kind of just
academic and like yeah if we crank
compute to infinity we can save five
samples. Um, yeah. What's the What's the
theoretic versus the in practice? Yeah.
So, I want to do that and then hopefully
we get something good from that. Uh,
that would put Puffer like so so far
ahead because like obviously the way I
will do it, right, is whatever I build
out of that is going to be at least 10x
simpler than whatever else is out there.
So, you're going to have fast and simple
version of whatever I come up with
there. um that is pretty much enough
that we can confidently be the best
choice for RL anywhere in solving
whatever problems there
are if it's not already clear that like
you know in specific domains for
instance in robotics like whatever yeah
some people have specialized stuff but
if we just get like general algorithms
better then we'll just have better stuff
um and then I think from
there I spend a little time growing the
company so we can get all our
servers and then I I think Puffer is
gonna ask I did want to ask Well, we'll
see. What is your ETA for being like
properly set up and start bringing in
new boxes into your new place? I ordered
I ordered two tiny boxes uh yesterday.
They'll be here in two weeks.
All righty.
That's 12 more GPUs.
Uh, I I'm just asking because my
schedule's about to get busy come the
end of June. We're not going to have
We're not going to have those like the
new like the 30 boxes or whatever for a
while, Linky, because it's got to be
when the tariffs come down. I can't be
paying plus 40. No, more. I could be
four years. Yeah, that's I would I
wouldn't go that far. I think they'll
start to drop by midterm. I think before
that I I would sincerely sincerely hope.
Um, but in the meantime though, I got us
plus 12 GPUs.
So, be able to do stuff with that. Come
on, Linky. 12490s.
Yeah, like I'm excited. Is that going to
be in a GPU server or are those going to
be dead like dedicated 12 different
machines? It's two boxes of six.
Okay, so actual like GPU server,
you can look them up there. It's tiny
box v1s. V1s should be faster than V2s
for us. They were also a bit cheaper.
Yeah. Um, it was Are you just planning
like usagewise to
just use those
GPUs together clustered or are you
thinking about separating them and like
designating one GPU per container and
having six containers per machine?
Um, a mix I would say. I think it's
going to be better used on like larger
jobs. So, I think it's going to let us
do larger scale stuff. Um,
but I think that there's also going to
be some room for like splitting it, but
it's only going to work for the really
fast ends to do that.
Yeah. And so, so what you're saying is
start thinking about ways
I don't freaking know. My mixer is
weird.
My bad. You're good.
Um, so start thinking of ways of
monitoring from a container level
instead of a box level on my part,
right?
Um, I mean, hardware-wise, we still care
more about the
boxes, but I think that's
fine. I think it's fine to still have
box level stuff. I'm also going to start
getting some of the boxes as soon as
those get here. I'm going to start
shipping some of the ones from Florida
that I have them all here for
maintenance. I'm not going to be here
like full year round, right? I'm going
to be in Florida some of the time and
I'm probably should spend a little bit
of time in Palo Alto just cuz like all
of the potential clients and stuff are
there.
Um, yeah, we'll see. And where, like,
you don't have to give me a specific
area because I know you're on stream,
but about where in the United States is
your new facility? I'm in Maryland.
I'm thinking like in case I have to fly
out there for any I'm trying to think of
like coverage purposes.
For
what? uh coverage purposes in the sense
of
like what if you want to go out on
vacation for like six months in Europe
or something for whatever reason like
what can we do to make like ensure
uptime I have nontech there are
non-technical people here that can do
stuff
I will say
um at some point this isn't
like set in stone or anything just at
some point I'd like a
uh preferably maybe meet in person. I
know that's kind of like risky I guess.
I don't know. I've been I've been and
that just so I can give you a run
through on like some of the hardware
ideas I've come up with to answer like
remote physical restarts and things like
that. Yeah, definitely. I Does that
makes I think that's like for when we
get all the boxes though, right? because
like right now we don't have so this
isn't this isn't anytime soon. I'm just
saying I do have ideas. I've got
prototypes to answer some of these
problems, but it's like I can't really
show in a stream capacity like how
things work. Yeah, no worries. I also
I'm we're going to see how stable stuff
is as well with the new ones. I like a
massive number of the problems
uh were just straight up the shitty
Intel chips, right?
Yeah. And I'm thinking you said these
machines are called Tiny Box V1.
Uh yeah, they're AMD chipped. I checked.
Is it by like Nant Studio?
No, it's the tiny corp. It's uh George.
Yeah, it's not that.
I mean, they're nice boxes. I got them
because I see I see. Yeah, I got them
because
um it was 12 GPUs for 50 grand. Um and I
was just not going to get anywhere near
that on desktops at the moment. Like
normally desktops should be around that
same price. It would probably be 55 50 5
or 5.55 or 55 or 56 for like
um even for 10 boxes. Like these were
actually pretty well speced for what
they are. I don't know if I really
needed two. I'd probably rather get one
of those in like six
individuals, but I can't really get the
individuals at a reasonable price. So I
figured it would be best to just have
these now. So we have some compute for
this will this will power a lot of open
source research. Uh we've had already
clients are like interested. They want
distributed training on stuff. So this
will let us do all that optimization and
testing inhouse. Um I thought it would
just be good overall. So this should be
a good this I think this will be a
worthwhile investment. It'll let us do a
lot of cool open source stuff, allow do
good old research stuff, and hopefully
also get some clients on this as well
with um some of the scale up stuff
because like you know once we start,
let's say that we go to even like 5
million parameter policies um you can do
a lot with a 5 million parameter policy
and then we get something like that
training at millions of steps per
second. Now we're talking, right? Well,
not only that, just like a from a VRAMm
perspective as well.
because I think by default now in
tougher live
well we pin everything to GPU right it's
not pinned
yeah so you don't we keep the tensors on
GPU but that's not really a big issue
and there is an offload option
how fast will it yeah oh you're right
there is off but it's not great like I
actually it so the thing I realized
today is I was really like One really
stupid thing I realized today is I kept
reading like the oh 1.8 terabyte
whatever memory transfer on like modern
GPUs. Uh yeah, dumbass me that's not the
number that matters. The number that
matters is PCIe and PCIe is only 32 gigs
up and down. So that's why we're
actually What gen is your PCIe? Because
that's where your IO actually is limited
where it connects to the board. Yeah.
So, actually, one thing I couldn't tell
here is um it says four, but then shows
as one on the really fast box, but like
the really fast box is faster than the
one that's like uh than the Gen 5 or
whatever I have locally. So, I think
that there's just like some weird
misreporting. I can't imagine that any
modern high-end motherboard wouldn't be
a five like PCIe 5, right?
Um Yes and no. Because now you're
fighting you're fighting the
um the RAM slots, the PCI slots, and the
chipset versus like what firmware and
what capabilities does the board
actually have. So as as easy as it would
be to say across the boards, if you have
this slot, then you're getting these
speeds, there's more than just that
that's limiting it. Like a prime example
is you can't just say all motherboards
with DDR3 have like PCI2 Express or
whatever the hell they name it. Let me
give you the good news on this though.
The good news is that this problem is
eventually going to go away because it's
actually pretty unlikely that we're
going to be doing more than 32 up 32
down. Uh if we get Gen 5 anyways or even
a fraction of that. The only problem is
at the moment like let's say that we're
doing three gigabytes even um and it's
it's not pinned because the way our
vectorization is at the moment. So it's
it's more like 3x that that's not done
async. Yeah. So it's done synchronously.
So that just adds flat 20% overhead.
Um, but I think what we're going to end
up doing is we're going to find we're
going to be able to have a way to async
ceue our data transfers so that we can
like
really not start to see any overhead or
latency uh until we are over the
PCIe transfer speed limits. Um, but
that's require me to do a lot of work.
I was going to say you could take a tip
from that guy and
um I guess like compress your data
like this is going to be a stretch to
explain it but instead of saying like
raw bits over you can send bytes over
converting from like instead of you know
zeros and one sending hex to decimal
over like the least amount of
information the most we have done that
before we've tried that it's it works
but that's not feasible for every
N they just send dense data.
I mean there are a few different things
in play as well. Like I think there are
a lot of places to optimize, but the
cool thing is like we're already so much
faster than everything else that
like it's kind of just going to be nice
to just be faster and faster and faster,
but like it's already super fast.
Um, but I don't think it makes sense to
just keep going nuts on pure perf
optimizations, at least until we've
circled back to do more algo stuff. So,
I really my hope is that look, I've
gotten most of this stuff into a decent
spot. Uh, if we see I actually just now
have
128 on breakout
here. See how fast this is.
Isn't Isn't more algo stuff just
Perf.
Not really. Okay, there you go. So, this
is matching right now. It's not doing
any better, but this is a 24 second
solve right here.
Um, so this will keep running
overnight. We're going to do like
similar final sweeps on everything.
We're going to really get some good
policies, some good train speeds and
stuff on everything is going to be the
goal. We're going to get to put out a
bunch of good material, hopefully drive
some users to Puffer, and then it's
going to be algo time. And algo time is
going to be like robustness, stability.
It's also going to be um like
fundamentally better learning curve, not
just faster on same learning curve
hopefully. Uh and it's also going to be
ability to scale for slower M, which is
very important.
Yeah.
So, it's going to be quite a lot. That
is
tangental
maybe. How
what are your thoughts on having a
standard puffer API
or what? Yeah, I mentioned it. You want
to look at the mini puffer?
No, I'm not I'm not even I'm not worried
about a mini puffer. Don't that's
honestly that's a project on my end to
keep things clean for me and I can see
how it could be beneficial for other
people. Setting that aside because I
literally that is just puffer live
without framework and all of the
environments. That's all it is.
Framework is from puffer.
Well that it was not in 1.0 when I
initially released many. I'm just
telling you I I already deleted
framework. Correct. Well, I just mean
like you still rely on the clean rl.py.
That's still in the puffer lib
directory. That's gone. Really? Yep. I'
I've done a lot. I'm going to have to
rewrite some stuff then
demo demo.ply plus plus clean puffl are
now one file and it's less than 900
lines of code.
Nice. I've done a lot of work. So, what
I what I mean by API is
like I I'm hesitant to call it the cream
of the crop, but the most well-known
findings that most people use for
environments are going to be your gym
and your
gymnasium API, if you want to call it
that. Um, you follow that and it works
with most machine learning.
standardizing that for not only Python
but C environments in puffer lib would
be amazing as well as just standardizing
like your uh your vectors your makes and
things like that so you don't have all
that boilerplate per environment every
time just standardizing something
boilerplate reduction very good boiler
plate reduction is very good very good
and I've been trying like that was the
new end bindings without siphon was
trying to help with that Um, I'm still
working on, you know, more of that, but
it's it's a lot better than it was. Um,
so I've heard I still have to go over
all the new binding PRs as well. I don't
think standardization is super important
at this point. Honestly, I think just
like making doing the making oneoffs
easy is more important. So like for
whatever the heck problem people have,
it should be easy to tailor a thing to
them more than it should be like try to
get it out of the box fully. Because if
you try to get like I think trying to
get it out of the box fully you're gonna
fail and you're gonna over complicate
it. That's my impression at the moment.
Yeah, I guess agree. But also Linky what
what he's doing is actually he doesn't
see it as as such but what he's doing is
actually doing what you're what you're
saying. uh it's not you know per se
standardization but what it is is doing
is making it so that there are there's
something that looks like an API but I'm
not committing to it as an API
calculator. Yeah. All right. There is
something that looks like an API but I'm
not committing I'm not committing to an
API if that makes sense. Like it's going
to keep changing. Yeah.
Okay. Yeah. That's the answer I was
looking for. Um, I want to do everything
I can, at least on my end, to not have
have to keep rewriting things. It's a
big part of the reason I stopped some
development on my environment because I
don't want to write the old Syon
bindings to have to change it to the new
bindings and all that. I just said I'll
wait until your 2.5 or your 3.0 release.
I just mean in my comingings and goings
because I frequent Reddit and I frequent
the reinforcement learning boards on
Reddit. There is unfortunately all those
people that want to halfass their
projects and stick to an API and that's
what makes something like
gymnasium so nice. We don't necessarily
care that much anymore because like the
thing is all those libraries aren't
going to be a like they're all so slow
and bad anyways. they're not going to be
able to solve the same types of problems
that Puffer would be able to solve. So
like in general, I don't care about
half-ass users unless they're paying and
then like
and then generally if the users are
paying like we're we will make it very
easy on them.
Um but I care about the users who are
actually going to like bother to try and
read things. Um and that's generally
like
You know, ideal users are people like,
"Oh, wow. Clean RL is great. I wish it
were fast and like could log and stuff,
right?" Yeah.
Yeah. That sounds like the major selling
point of puffer, honestly. Yeah. So, I
don't know. It's I I think this release
will be pretty dang good. I have to do
still a whole bunch of work. I need to
get some rest because I've just been
grinding this thing constantly.
Um, but like we're making we're making
very good progress
here. Uh, so I'm going to call it I'm
going to call it a night and uh I will
be back on Monday most likely.